Here are a couple of examples. I'm sure
that you may have thought of other examples
as well. But packet filter is one thing
that I mentioned already to you. And this
is something that may be a critical component
of performance for any operating system. And therefore,
it might install a packet filter for demultiplexing
incoming network packets so that exokernel can hand packets
intended for a particular library operating system by
running this code on behalf of the library
operating system. A second example would be things
that a library would like exokernel to do on
its behalf, even when it is not currently
scheduled. For instance, a garbage collection mechanism for an
application is something that a library operating system
may want to be run on behalf of it.
And that's something that can be installed as a
code that is downloaded into exokernel and executed on behalf
of that library operating system. So these are all
examples, you may have thought of other examples as well.